Enterprise is a
huge opportunity.
When most developers
think about Android,
they look at the general
end user numbers,
but often they forget about
the massive opportunity
available for business devices.
My name is Matt, and
with Android for Work,
you can take advantage
of this huge opportunity.
Did you know that
as of 2014, there
were 250 million
Android devices in use
in businesses around the world?
And it continues to grow
strongly in two flavors.
Bring Your Own
Device, or BYOD, is
where the employee
owns their device
but their company
also allows them
to use it for work, currently at
175 million devices and growing
at 15% per year.
On the other hand,
corporate liable
is where the company
owns their device
and typically only allows it
to be used for work, currently
around 75 million devices
and growing at 8% per year.
Compare that to the 1 billion
Android devices in use today,
and that's already 25%
being used in businesses.
So how do you reach
this massive market?
Start with Google Play
for Work to get your apps
into the hands of businesses.
Google Play for Work provides
a dedicated storefront
to businesses using
Android for Work.
Google Play for
Work, when combined
with Android for Work devices,
allows a whole set of control
and install options
for IT admins.
This is why it's been integrated
by these top Enterprise
Mobility Management
companies, or EMMs.
This gives your app
exposure to a broad range
of business customers.
IT admins are able to
install your application
across an entire workforce
at the click of a button.
We are working with more
EMMs to get them on board
as quickly as possible.
Using Google Play for Work as
a developer is straightforward.
You're able to ship your apps
to both Google Play and Google
Play for Work within the
Pricing and Distribution
tab of the familiar
Play Developer Console.
But what if you have
a paid application?
At I/O 2015, we made
it possible for IT
admins to purchase
paid apps in bulk
within Google Play for Work.
It's now possible
for an IT admin
to buy multiple licenses of
your app in one transaction
and then distribute
them to employees
who are using Android for Work.
This gives you the
opportunity to grow your user
base more quickly.
The licenses are
owned by the company,
so if an employee
leaves, then the company
can transfer that
license to another user.
That means it is
critical for you
to keep track of which users
have licenses assigned.
We recommend that your app
uses the Google Play Licensing
API to periodically
check ownership.
Now, it's important
to understand
that IT admins for
businesses typically
have stricter security
concerns than regular users.
Here's a quick
checklist of items
to keep your eye on as
you're developing your app.
Firstly, IT admins will
scrutinize your permissions
closely before making your app
available to their employees,
so make sure you're only
requesting permissions
that you really need.
Make sure user data is
secured and encrypted
in transit and while
on your servers.
Consider also describing
the security measures
that you take in your
Google Play app description.
Data leaks caused
either accidentally
or maliciously
from your employees
will really put
businesses off your app.
Set authorization policies
within your business
to minimize the
number of employees
that can access user data.
Finally, avoid
features that might
cause information
security issues,
like sharing with
social networks,
or allow these to
be disabled by IT
admins using managed
configuration
through the Android App
Restrictions framework.
For more information
on app restrictions
and testing your enterprise app,
watch our previous video here.
So does your app
have the potential
to make a difference
to an entire workforce?
Whether it be barcode
scanners for warehouse staff,
collaboration tools for
remote office workers,
or stock market
tickers for finance,
there are countless
opportunities
opening up with Android for
Work and Google Play for Work.
Which one is knocking
on your door?
[MUSIC PLAYING]